it's not great hello and welcome to New
World review I am Grantland waifu and
I'm doing everything I can not to talk
about your soul or beanies because I've
been told not to discuss your soul or
beanies
it's banned content but it's fine
because I can enthrall you in other ways
like a special guest let's give our hand
to Hisoka who has kindly offered to join
us for a very brief interview so Sookie
can I call you Sookie thanks Sookie now
I hear you love to give a thumbs up or
thumbs down depending on your level of
enjoyment sorry that's my mistake I hear
you love to give a thumb up or down
depending on how much you like and
experience you're having now I'd like
you to give a thumb up or down in
response to the following words cards
dismemberment gone
Hisoka please put your thumb down that's
inappropriate Sookie please I'm sorry
everyone we're going to have to dive
into discussing the episodes because so
Kees being a little inappropriate
Sookie get out from under the bed and
pull yourself together man
episode 13 there will be spoilers
there have been spoilers there will
continue to be spoilers now the first
thing that must be said is that the
opening of this episode was really quite
beautiful
we had the simplicity and the cool
calmness of the boys learning how to use
nan nan yen but the smoky calmness and
the use of the art in a semblance of
incense was a really lovely way to give
us a reminder of what they've learned
learning that 10 could also slow the
effects of aging as a new piece of
information too it's nice to have a
solid objective reason for the Ash
effect when we get 10 10 years down the
line and neither God nor Kiowa have aged
at all they've hardened their bodies and
given themselves a shroud as it were
against the effects of the world
did anyone warn them that that would
happen before they started studying that
they would likely look like children
forever because they're using a mystical
power you shouldn't use until you've
finished maturing into a full human
being it's like how when puck was about
six months old the vet said now let him
keep his nuts for now so you can fill
out the vet doesn't sound like that at
all anyway he used to look like this now
he looks like this see the difference in
megistus ism and now these kids are
going to be halted and misunderstood for
the rest of their lives the energy of
this first battle was quite enjoyable it
was like
being back in a Pokemon Stadium except
our main character was Pikachu instead
of ash the heavy strings and bass giving
way to silence is a musical theme we've
seen several times and it was used to
great effect in the fight the return of
the beat has gone thought through the
idea and the victorious strings and
brass were bouncy too we as an audience
could have been forgiven for thinking he
would be fine especially since the last
episode suggested he couldn't do
anything basically Gahan was put up
against a strategist a boring one I was
glad he said it himself because the
strategy of make everything spin and
spin myself was in fact boring but the
outcome of it was to put the emphasis
back on gone and his problem-solving
gone did not make himself any friends
with this episode in fact we found he
has two nursemaids Qi and wing I found
it interesting that wing came in and
said exactly what Kiowa said and I love
the balancing act between Gahan and
Kilowog there's a real delicate
friendship between them gon coming to
rescue Kiowa because Kiowa is his friend
but didn't know it then keel while
becoming a mother hand around gone the
relationship is despite their sociopathy
and neutrality to the rest of society
really touching to watch their like a
filmer and Louise of the anime world
taking over one place at a time
except for wherever his Sokka is though
his Sokka really seems to want them to
win which is another thing in my crusade
for beanie wearing his Sokka to have his
own spin-off series why is it that he
has such a deep interest in gone why has
he placed so much attention on grooming
and harvesting collecting killing gone
why not kill one Qi is fair and more
obviously ripe for the picking he's a
better target he's the same age and
though he hasn't finished learning he
may be worth more in terms of actual
worth than gone Qi himself has rated his
abilities as closer to his Soaker than
gone so it seems strange that his Sokka
shows no interest in at all in the boy
and we as an audience get no chance to
see how kilwa would have gone in a fight
because Kiawah to be fair to him did the
responsible thing and has decided to
train first before jumping into the ring
finally finally an adult is taking the
oddness of God seriously the sheer
sociopathic danger that gahan gives the
world has finally been noticed by
someone relatively normal if we can call
chicken wing normal yes his shirt is
untucked
we're spending a lot of time making him
look unassuming but he knows how to use
her nanana nanan which means he probably
has a reason to learn to use it had a
reason to learn to use it help me
grammar and someone who thought he
should learn he has access to the 200th
floor and he knows how Godot riots I
mean anyone can watch but that's that's
my point
I do wonder what route he took how he
defeated Ito maybe we'll find out one
day but no he's not entirely normal he
is however the most well-adjusted adult
we've seen in the series so far so we
have to let it slide he had the response
to God trying out a fight that we really
would hope a grown-up would have a
responsible normal not you Hisoka adult
human would think no please child you do
not have the appropriate training nor do
you have appropriate PPE do not I repeat
do not go out into the ring to fight
against a man who is better with small
toys than you and beyond that when he
heard that Gahan went into the ring to
continue his training chicken had that
even better reaction while the what do
you think that's a good idea
and we saw him prancing around like he
was in a shampoo commercial didn't know
what else think that was weird he
figured out the solution and his
decision his grand plan was to just
suddenly have the urge to herbal with
spinning tops of doom not only did he
engage in a sociopathic level of calm in
a situation that required in my humble
opinion a complete freak out for at
least a moment but he did it for fun and
learning I mean to a degree I get it I'm
a doctoral student I have to understand
the masochistic enjoyment of engaging in
a life-or-death battle for an outcome
that's not going to be as good as you
think it will be just because but still
still karappa Carr such a coincidence
that you are undergoing the same
training as gone in kiel wha
would you look at that if the audio
doesn't do the same it's going to be
very awkward when they're all seeing
things he does not let's hope we find
out about Leigh oreos experience in
episode 31 episode 31 of course God is
okay and Kela is as shocked as the rest
of us except we aren't shocked are we
because we know that Gaughan isn't human
as much as we know that key lies in fact
some kind of rat life-form GaN repairs
quickly if he didn't he couldn't do all
the reckless things he does that make
him cool or really terrifyingly
dangerous again wing understands or is
beginning to understand that the real
danger isn't Kilwa it's gone he was a
sociopath but he's a sociopath with
boundaries that he actually uses and
enforces gone is a sociopath who doesn't
really know what boundaries are for the
first time he's got someone who is
enforcing them for him and he's sticking
to them I have no doubt that GaN will in
fact do as wing says for as long as it
works for him as soon as he has a
stronger handle on his feminine in there
will go all of wings control over him
and wing was absolutely right to tell
him not to study because wing can see
that if GaN sees how nen is used GaN
will then use the nen the tiny string on
gongs finger became a very highlighted
factor of all of God's appearances in
this episode and I found I really
appreciated the importance of promises
because the physical representation of
promise is absolutely necessary for a
character like god we've seen how he
reacts when he's just asked not to do
something promise or not kill why would
do what he wants and tried to skirt the
rules if they didn't suit him as he said
an episode or two ago if wing doesn't
train
they'll learn about it anyway and he
knows that gon obeys rules when it's
important to a goal he would have
exactly the same knowledge as keel 1
they're going to learn this thing that
exists where the wing wants them to or
not but gone see something in wings
treatment exploitation comes in many
different forms gone wants what wing has
and he's not going to fight for it if
he'll just get it by waiting for a bit
speaking of waiting for a bit gone would
have loved to sit in a bush for the
fight that he actively turned the
television off for it's interesting that
God misses this battle because I think
missing it is going to very much become
a plot point down the road as to who
he's missing my love is Olga has
returned and it seems he may have
competition you're going to have to bear
with me here because things may get out
of hand it would appear that his soccer
will have his hands full with this new
dashing man who has disarmed us all with
his charming smile and behavior outside
the ring his interaction with Kiowa and
the fact that he so easily managed to
catch the boy off-guard especially Kilwa
who has shown he has supernatural
perception and maturity for his age as
someone who can stand up to Kiowas
abilities it quickly proved without
getting into a combat scenario with
killer that he does have the ability to
take on his Soaker manoa manner by the
end of the episode there was a concern
that perhaps a win would slip through
his fingers such an experience would
have been a one-of-a-kind tale that God
would have had to learn from kilauea
second hand but I highly doubt that the
handy double castro has will actually
continue to get his dirty mitts on his
oka still it was delicious seeing Castro
actually managing to get some hits in on
Hisoka
you have to hand it to him though
actually cutting off his sokka's right
arm was incredible I wonder at this
point where the Hisoka is going to reach
the goal of defeating not this time
those were feet his opponent but maybe
he has a plan up his sleeve because
frankly he doesn't have an armour hey or
at least not now notably his arm didn't
bleed and he doesn't seem to be too
concerned whether that's his soak is
special or no I'm unsure but there's no
harm in charming leaf trying to farm
alarm in a man of full of smile it
doesn't seem to me at this point that
anyone in this show besides the audio is
actually human the audio very much seems
human with human ways but seeing all the
hunters we have to now and seeing the
intensity if the power flowing through
them I do wonder whether there
different species here I mean cut up
because eyes turn red like rubies as a
thing kilowatt turns into a rat and
kills people for a living as a small
child gone heals far too quickly wind
just instinctively makes me narrow my
eyes and even little Zushi concerns me
when it comes to how much of a beating
he can take without being broken to
pieces there's only so much practice you
can get a falling and only so many times
you can cough up blood before you've got
someone with the knowledge of basic
anatomy saying there's something going
on here with these individual physical
abilities all things considered I
understand that this is most certainly
fictional and I most certainly
understand that people can be superhuman
but still human in anime it's just that
up until now the conceit has been that
the people involved in the hunter exam
were human and now we're very much
leaving that idea behind the longer we
don't see lay audio that becomes even
more of a consideration
I suppose we'll see in time to come
whether that is in fact the case but for
now that's it from me I hope you've
enjoyed this episode there's this thing
here that you might want to click this
other thing over here that you might
want to click baby quick thing below if
you like this video share like subscribe
that's what the cool kids say check out
the discord and make sure you acquire a
beanie because it's required costuming
for this series goodbye